el aparente acercamiento entre China y
Estados Unidos ha durado poco el motivo
de la discordia un comentario del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
durante un evento de recaudación de
fondos del partido demócrata en el que
equiparólogo chino con un dictador el
motivo por el que se enfadó cuando
derribe ese globo con dos compartimentos
llenos de material de espionaje fue que
no sabía que estaba allí hablo en serio
Eso es una gran vergüenza para los
dictadores cuando no saben lo que ha
pasado
se refería a lo sucedido en febrero
cuando las autoridades estadounidenses
descubrieron un globo espía chino y lo
derribaron en Carolina del Sur escalando
las tensiones y propiciando una de las
peores crisis diplomáticas entre las dos
naciones rivales no obstante tras la
visita del secretario de estado Anthony
blinquen a China el fin de semana los
dos países se mostraron dispuestos a
dialogar e intentar normalizar las
relaciones bilaterales algo que el
comentario de biden enérgicamente
rechazado por China
los comentarios de la parte de Estados
Unidos fueron extremadamente ridículos e
irresponsables han violado gravemente
los hechos básicos y el protocolo
diplomático así como la dignidad
política de China
no es la primera vez que el presidente
de Estados Unidos hace una intervención
así durante un evento de campaña el
octubre pasado habló sobre una supuesta
amenaza de Armagedón nuclear por parte
de Rusia